je crois simplement que aujourd'hui
c'est plus dur pour nous par rapport à
la génération de nos parents pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord avec la chuute
du mur de Berlin les les différentes les
différents repères identitaires sont
moins netes qu'il l'était avant pour
s'engager ouais et ensuite je crois
aussi que le fait d'aller voter de se
rendre aux urnes il faut le corréler
avec le moment où on entre dans la
société et où finalement on est on passe
du du jeune au jeune adulte on va dire
qui a sont qui a un emploi qui travaille
et qui donc se sent actif dans la
société veut et contribuer or
aujourd'hui voilà on a 23 % de chômage
chez les jeunes 40 % dans certaines
banlieu euh c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de se sentir investi dans la
société et de pouvoir contribuer mais je
crois pas que les jeunes soient
dépolitisés absolument pas les jeunes je
pense ont plus de conviction que jamais
et on les a vu dans la rue au moment du
CPE on les a vu dans la rue au moment de
Jean-Marie Le Pen au second tour est-ce
qu'il ferait un bon politique moi je VO
moi je voterai pour lui dire j'ai dit
j'ai dit Gaby
président Président c'est lui le futur
président futur oua donc ces images
vautent très très cher il nous a déjà
attribuer min
fonctions on est déjà des fonctionséta
pas au courant